I was like pretty happy at Google,
but I felt like I could be like happier doing something else.
So I hope you don't mind me asking, but like, so how much do you make,
uh, with CS dojo now? Uh,
so it's kinda tricky because it goes up and down a little bit. Okay. Uh,
but I would say the average for the past few months has
been about 10,000 us dollars per month. Yeah.
Before we continue as this video,
I just want to say that this video is sponsored by go.co.
now.co domains are dope. They're pretty much the hottest domains.
Like for example, vine.co. Now, if you watch my startup series,
you would know that I have a startup called not fine.
So I actually wanted to get not vine.co because I
really want it to mimic vine.co. Unfortunately, when I checked the website,
it wasn't available. Someone took it before me.
I wonder if they watch my series, but basically they took it before me. And, uh,
unfortunately can't get that, but I was able to get
revived.co by the way, Revine is basically my nemesis startup,
which is exactly the same as not mine.
I haven't fully decided what to do with it yet,
but I'm pretty sure that it's going to be something video related either.
I can just have it as an alias for kind of like my portfolio for all my videos,
or I can have like a user submitted video platform that I can make. We'll see,
we'll see. Anyways, back to go.co.
So go.co is a place to find.co domains. And like I said,
dot co is pretty dope. Dot co is basically like.io,
but way cooler, like.io. So old fashioned,
it's not cool anymore. Nobody uses that anymore. It's all about.co.
Now all the hottest startups use.co for example, like I said,
fine.co and there's other ones like angel.co.co bird.co.
These are all like super dope companies.
They have over 2.2 million domains registered worldwide.
It's short, so you can easily type it on your phone. It's memorable.
So if you have a startup, it's a very unique name for your brand,
which is very useful for a startup. So if you want to register a.co domain,
go to go.co and register your domain now, and then also build something with it.
I can't wait to see what you guys build.
All right. So welcome. Um,
I usually don't like talk to the camera anymore. I drive to you, but yeah,
pretty much stay with question. Yeah. So anyways, um, yeah,
so you want to just give a little introduction to like my viewers and stuff like
that, like for example, your name or channel itself, like sure. Yeah.
Just real quick. All right.
I guess I'm going to talk into the camera if you want. Yeah. Whatever. Uh,
so as you know, my name is Y K, uh,
and I'd been running, you know, my YouTube channel, uh,
called CSL joke.
It's a programming and discussion YouTube channel that I've been running for the
past three years now, the first year I did it, part-time, uh, you know,
while I was working at Google as a software developer and then the
past two years have been full time, uh, you know,
a lot of people ask me like, can I make a living out of it?
And the answer is yes, I can. And that's what I've been doing. Cool.
So, yeah, I mean, honestly, I'm like super impressed that, you know,
you were able to like, quit your job at Google and then start like YouTube,
like pretty much full-time now. Um, yeah, so I was wondering like,
is like, I've seen the video of what you could Google,
but do you want to just like talk about it again, then the house,
maybe more questions about it. Yeah.
So why did you quit Google and started YouTube, right? Full-time now. Yeah.
Full time.
Yeah. Uh, so, you know,
this is something I've already talked about on this channel, like you mentioned.
Yeah. But I sort of thought about it again for this particular interview
and here's the way I think about it. Uh, you know, there are,
there are sort of two parts to it. The first part was that, you know,
I wanted to like spend more time on YouTube, get better at, you know,
making videos and basically help more people. And then the second part was that,
uh, I was like pretty happy at Google,
but I felt like I could be like happier doing something else. So maybe like.
You know, either of them, if you want me to yeah. Both of them.
Yeah, sure. Uh, so the YouTube part, uh, you know, this one,
I think there are like two ways of thinking about it. Uh,
and both of them are true. The first one is that, you know,
I had about 7,000 subscribers and maybe like,
um, you know, about a hundred thousand total views at that point,
like right before I left Google. Wow. Okay. Yeah. So it's, it's like,
it's not like a lot of views, but it's, you know, it's some traction.
Yeah. That's pretty gutsy. Cause like, yeah.
I wouldn't like I would be too afraid to do it even now for my channel.
Right. Yeah. I like, I was pretty afraid, but I still like, sort of did it and,
you know, I had like a few courses going on and I was making, uh, I don't know,
like 300, $400 from those courses,
like a month or a month and basically nothing from YouTube.
So what w my original idea was okay,
if I can make like 10 more courses like that,
I will make like three to four K a month and that's going to be enough for like
rent and food and everything else.
So that that's sort of the financial plan I had.
And at the same time, I, I, you know,
I thought that I would be able to help a lot more people, you know,
through my YouTube channel with them through my job.
So that's sort of one way of looking at it, uh, the other way of looking at it,
which is also true is that I saw this business opportunity and I didn't want to
miss it. Right, right, right. That makes a lot of sense. Yeah.
Okay. So I hope you don't mind me asking, but like,
so how much do you make, uh, with CS dojo now?
Uh, so it's kind of tricky because it goes up and down a little bit. Okay. Uh,
but I would say the average for the past few months has
been about 10,000 us dollars per month.
Nice. Yeah. And then the breakdown was like 40%. Um, yeah.
Okay. That's the same break now. Yeah. Wow. That's pretty cool. Nice.
Do you want to make more or like, are you okay with that now?
I'm happy with it. You know, like I said earlier,
I want to be able to stabilize my income a little bit more,
but I don't see any reason to like, make more because like,
I can do everything on my own, like editing shooting.
Cool. Awesome. Yeah. But like,
it's crazy how you validated this business opportunity just with like your
YouTube channel. Cause you know, a lot of times when you hear about startups,
they always talk about, okay, you build the NDP, validate your idea,
and then you go all in.
So can you kind of say that your YouTube channel when it was only 7,000
subscribers that was already an MVP?
Yeah, that was, that was one of the MVPs I had. Okay.
Were you ever scared that like, Oh, maybe it won't grow anymore.
And it's the top? I was actually super scared until like,
maybe like six months in. So like I left Google, uh,
two years ago in April, may, something like that.
And then I think if I remember correctly in August or September of the
same year, like six months after I quit my job,
I was making like a thousand dollars a month. And I was like, I like, I,
I spending a lot more than I'm making. Yeah. But like, as a,
as a kid, you know, I just like going, I guess, what was that?
The, the biggest pulling factor? Was it that, Oh,
there's like a big business opportunity or was it like, Oh,
I really want to help a lot.
Of people, both, like, I would say equally.
Equally important for the business opportunity. Like,
were you more motivated by like how much money potentially can you get or, okay.
So.
Not like not the amount of money I would say it's more about, uh,
the, sort of the stability that comes from being a business owner,
because when you're on an employee, no matter how good the company is,
there's always a risk of either being laid off or being fired. Right.
And like, I don't see Google doing that anytime soon,
but it's possible like in 10, 20 years. So I thought like,
by having a business, you know,
my financial situation will be like stable in the longterm. Basically.
It's really funny. Cause like most people, when they don't want to go, you know,
start your own business or start your own startup is because they have more
financial stability in a company.
So I'm very surprised that you're actually like, yeah.
Yeah. It's, it's a funny way or thinking about it.
But the way I think about it is, you know, in the short term,
it's obviously more stable to have a job, but in the longterm, I mean,
my business is still pretty unstable,
but if I have like two or three businesses, I don't have to like rely on,
you know, one of them to like, got it. Got it. Yeah. Yeah. So,
so like when I made those videos back then I was definitely making, you know,
a lot less money, I would say, I don't remember exactly,
but I think it was like two, three K a month. Uh,
but now it's like comparable to what I used to make it.
What do you use to make? Okay. Yeah. So can you tell me more about like the,
all the Reverend or like all the sources of income that you get and like,
which was the biggest, you know, just so that if ever you guys want to do it,
you can try or they could at least know how it goes.
Yeah, of course. Uh,
so I guess the first thing I would say about that is that it's really tough,
you know, doing, you know, doing business on YouTube. Uh,
but for me at the breakdown, I think is about like,
I would say 40 to 45% YouTube ad revenue,
40 to 50 or 40 to 45% something like, something like that. Yeah.
This is not the exact number, but that's sort of the rough number.
And then the rest is my courses. Uh, you know,
I feel like it marketing next sponsorships. I did a little bit, but you know,
it's not, it's not on the ongoing payment. Okay.
Sponsorship, meaning like a flat rate, right? Yeah. Okay. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah.
That's pretty funny. Cause like, for me, um,
to ad revenue is very little, um,
I think it's probably like maybe 20%. Okay. Yeah.
And then everything else is just a flat rate. Sponsorships.
I just started doing the affiliate link recently with algo expert IO.
And I actually use the other one too, that you use,
which is daily coding problem. Yeah. I use my promo code if you want.
No
[inaudible] no, I was just kidding. [inaudible].
And um, yeah, so far it seems like that's okay too, but yeah, like for me,
I just do like a lot of flat rate sponsorships and um, and yeah,
those ones are pretty good so far.
Are you thinking that you might expand in terms of monetization? How?
Yeah, so for monetization,
I'm happy where I am because I'm at a point where, you know,
I can basically afford my rent and food and everything else
and that's basically all I need. Uh, but you know, content wise,
um, yeah, I'm still thinking about it.
I was thinking maybe like more interview, uh,
kind of videos or podcasts or maybe going into machine
learning or something.
Yeah. Yeah. That makes sense.
I remember you making a video about quantum computers. Yeah. Like,
are you interested in like the most novel tech and stuff like that? No.
No, no, no, not necessarily.